This video is made possible by brilliant,
so you're going to learn more about
brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn
more about them right now,
you've got a brilliant.org/buyer
graphics and also find a link in the
description below.
We're not behind for the annual
prices that he gifted to the welds,
but Alfred Nobel also left us
with another legacy explosives.
He was the inventor of dynamite and
it's even more deadly incarnation.
Jelic night. They made him
rich beyond his wildest dreams,
but also left him with a tortured
conscience. In this week's biographics,
we examine the life of Alfred
Nobel Alfred Bernard Nobel
was born on August the 21st
1833 in Stockholm in Sweden.
He was a sickly child.
He almost died after the first
week of his birth as it was.
He was one of just four of
eight children to survive.
His illness kept him indoors while
his three brothers played outside.
Alfred's father Emmanuel was an
inventor and he's an engineer,
but he struggled to run lines.
His ambitions as a result of the family.
It struggled to get by just the three
months prior to Alfred's, his birth,
his father had been forced to declare
bankruptcy and shut down his business.
Emanuel was now being chased by creditors.
Things that came almost unbearable when
a fire ravaged the family home tells me
against me to the Nobel children web sent
out into the streets to sell matches.
Alfred was an extremely
pallet and sickly child.
He suffered from epileptic convulsions
along with a host of gastric diseases and
debilitating migraine headaches.
For the first six years of his life,
Alfred were schooled by his mother.
He proved himself to be a gifted student
from the start. By the age of three.
He was able to read from that time onward.
He was rarely seen without
a book in his hand.
He also had an amazing memory
when Alfred was four years old,
his father moved to Russia in order to
pursue a business venture and manual had
managed to get a meeting with the
chairman of the Science Committee for the
Promotion of Industry and trade.
He steered the conversation
towards lands mines,
his area of expertise,
and was able to secure an invitation to
Turkey to meet some influential people
and on your worked in Tokyo for two
years where he invented the product.
We know today as plywood.
He then moved to Saint Petersburg.
There he was introduced to son Nicholas
the first season that the opportunity
and told the czar about his plans to
develop a submerged explosive mine.
Nicholas immediately saw the potential
to use the invention to prevent enemy
ships from entering into Russian waters.
Okay.
Things are looking up for the Nobels with
the money he received from the Russian
government is compensation
for his developments of the
submerged explosive mine
and manual setup,
a mechanical workshop and Armaments
Factory as well as making the new mind.
The factory also produced industrial tools
and cannon shells in 1842 when Alfred
was nine years old, manual send for
his family join him from Stockholm.
The new life of the Nobels was vastly
different to what they're known in Sweden.
That's and Peter's bag house was luxurious
in comparison to their old home and
manual was now able to
hire a tutor for his sons.
Unlike his brother's Alfred
was studious and intellectual.
He was also intensely curious
about the world around him.
He loved the poetry of Percy Shelley,
especially those concerns with the
subjects of nature and justice.
From these readings, he developed a
deep desire to stand up to injustice.
Alfred's other loves where
chemistry and languages.
By the time he was 17 he
could speak five languages.
His father also recognized in the by a
natural affinity for solving problems.
Marking Alfred is the most promising
of his sons to follow in his inventive
steps.
The boy loved nothing better than to
spend his time and his father's factory
silently taking in everything that
his dad was doing before long.
His father allowed him to
handle the chemicals himself.
Alfred Street has encouraged his
passion for chemistry and literature.
At the same time, they coaxed him
to come out of his shell socially,
largely as a result of his l healthy
was a painfully shy and introverted boy.
Yup.
With the help of his tutors.
He began to stretch himself
academically and his mid teens.
He had a gun participating in debate in
clubs and started to share his passions
with family members.
Then around the age of 15 he had a growth
spurt which puts him at the height of
most of his peers. This went a
long way to boost his confidence.
In 1850 Emmanuel paid for
Alfred deep study in Paris.
He had already been studying with
chemists and Nikolai is in and it was
chemistry that he pursued in France.
Empower Paris,
offered spend time with Ascanio
subreddit Rowe who had recently invented
nitroglycerin.
Breira was totally opposed to any
commercial use of his invention due to its
highly unpredictable explosive potential,
in fact,
in later life and made the following
statements about his invention.
When I think of all the victims kills
during nitroglycerin explosions and the
terrible havoc that it wreaks,
which in all probability will
continue to occur in the future.
I'm almost ashamed to admit
to being it's discover up.
Sabrina is a version two is discovery
did not put off young. No Bell. In fact,
the reverse history,
the substance fascinated Alfred Nobel
and met a chemist by the name of Jules
Pelosi,
who was fascinated with nitroglycerin
and had a determination to bring it under
control.
After a year in France,
Alfred went into the United States to
pursue his studies that he worked with.
Swedish invented Jon Erickson.
Erickson would go on to gain fame as the
inventor of ironclad warships used in
the civil war, as well as the inventor
of this group. Propeller Erickson,
Phil's Alfred's minds with dreams of what
he could do if he was able to team the
nitroglycerin. After a year in America,
Alfred returned to some peaches bag.
It's probably recognized
a changed young man.
His brother Ludvig recalls Alfred
to grown so that I hardly knew him.
He has almost as tall as I and his voice
has become so deep and strong that I
didn't recognize it, but Alfred
did more than change physically.
The young man who had left with lots
of ideas but little direction now had a
goal to turn nitroglycerin
into a commercially usable
blasting agents for use in
tunnels and to create fear,
inspiring weapons of war that were so
terrible that nations would be deterred
from ever going to war in the first place.
First though,
Alfred had to come to
the help of the family.
He works alongside his brothers
and one of his father's factories,
but the physical work proved
too much for his weekend body.
He was often too sick to work and on
one occasion in 1854 he became so unwell
that his father passed him off to the
spa town of friends and bad to recuperate
by now in manuals business,
it was flourishing is submerged explosive.
Mine was in high demands
along with other munitions.
Do you supply the Russian
forces in fighting?
The Crimean war of 1853 through 1856 by
1853 Emmanuel was employing more than a
thousand people in his factories and the
Russian government was so pleased with
him that they awarded him the imperial
gold medal in recognition of his
diligence and creative skill in Russian
industry in between overseeing years
manufacturing and buyer Emmanuel found
time to collaborate with Alfred on the
nitroglycerin problem,
but even in manual with his vast
experience could not find a safe way to
detonate the substance.
The ends of the Crimean war in 1856 saw
a sharp downtown in business for the
Nobel Company and I knew what was forced
to change his focus from armaments
productions you shining out
household and industrial implements,
but still the business
suffered by 1859 and manual.
Found himself facing bankruptcy for
the second time. He closed the factory,
liquidators his assets and moved with his
wife and youngest son and mill back to
Sweden.
Alfred and his two older brothers loot
Vegan Robert stayed on and some Peter's
bag.
28 year old Ludvig was given the job of
consolidating and running the remnants
of the Nobels Russian operation.
He rebranded the company as the
Ludvig Nobel mechanical factory.
Alfred spends about four hours each day
helping out with the family business the
rest of the day. He worked on his
passion to team Nitroglycerin.
Alfred's first step was to learn to create
nitroglycerin himself by 1861 year to
accomplish that goal after spending up
to 18 hours a day in a small factory
building.
The first breakthrough came
when he discovered how to
transport a nitroglycerin
safely by first soaking yet and coldest.
Now,
suddenly Nitroglycerin was a viable
explosive engineering companies from all
over the world came to the Nobel company
to purchase the products and as the
money started rolling in Alfred's next
challenge was to find a safe way to
designate the nitroglycerin.
And September of 1864 though tragedy
struck the Swedish Nobel company factory.
A Vat of Nitroglycerin had been overheated
and the resulting explosion five
people were killed, including
Alfred's younger brother and mill.
Alfred himself was working
in the next building,
anti suffered minor injuries and the
disaster rather than being pushed off from
working with Nitroglycerin.
Alfred threw himself into making the
explosive safer to give up now would be in
his view to allow his
brother to have died in vain.
In 1865 he built a factory in Hamburg,
Germany.
It's so happens that the soil arounds
the Hamburg factory and we're special.
It's contained.
Minute particles are fossils.
When nitroglycerin was poured into the
style, it turns into a dewy consistency.
This process and affects
puts the Nitroglycerin to
sleep in order to wake it up
for detonation purposes.
Nobel bell invented the blasting cap.
Alfred knew that a fuse could not be used
directly to detonate nitroglycerin bus.
That gunpowder could be used to
detonate it a few years could be used to
designate the gunpowder, which would
then ignite the nitric restaurant.
By 1867 he had mastered the use of Small
Cup of capsules of Mercury fulminate,
which was ignited by a fuse
to detonate the nitroglycerin.
This blasting cap would
wake up the Nitroglycerin,
which was packed into a doe soil base,
Nobel calls the combination of
nitroglycerin blasting and soil dynamite,
Nobel patented dynamite and began
putting it on the commercial market.
It was an immediate success with engineers
from all over the world clamoring to
get their hands on it.
Virtually overnight Alfred became rich.
Beyond his wildest dreams.
We can get an idea of how much
money came in by an anecdote,
apparently true concerning his house
maids wedding when Alfred Asta what she
would like as a gift. The various astute
go replied as much as you make in a day.
The following day,
Nobel gave her a check for $100,000
Alfred and self never married,
but he did have at least three
great loves throughout his life.
While living in Russia in his early
twenties he fell for a Russian Gal by the
name of Alexandria,
painfully shy.
He finally built up the gumption to
tell the girl how he felt about her,
but his affections, what roundly
rejected the rebuff, hurting badly,
and for the next 20 years he refused
to let his heart be broken again.
Nobel consciously portrayed
himself as a [inaudible],
an eccentric he wants to
rate the following about
himself. I'm a misanthrope,
yet utterly benevolence. Have more than
one screw loose. Yes, I'm a super idea.
This two digests philosophy
more efficiently than the food.
Even though he had money to purchase
literally anything he wanted,
Alfred was rather frugal.
This may have been a reflection of the
extreme poverty that he had experienced
in his childhood.
He had no interest in purchasing such
tokens of wealth is elegant carriage
clothing or food,
but would invest liberally in new
estates and business ventures.
Nobel was known to have a temper and he
was a man who did not suffer fools with
many occasions being recorded
where he was rude with people.
Usually those who worked for him, he was
a get to the point type of guy. Yeah.
Do you also have the ability to charm
potential investors when the need
warranted it.
In 1870 Alfred apparently
tired of his life of solitude and placed
an advertisement in the newspaper that
read as follows,
wealthy,
highly educated gentleman seeks Lady
of mature age vast in languages as
secretary and supervisor of households.
After interviewing a number of applicants,
Alfred employed a woman by the
name of birth or sky, 33 year olds.
Bertha was extremely attractive and
Nobel was immediately attracted to up.
It was also taken with obvious
intelligence and wit that's birth.
It did not return her
employers a factions. In fact,
she already had a fiance or after a few
months probably feeling and that he is
with the situation.
She resigned,
doesn't Nobel's secretary still the two
remained friends and they maintained an
active letter correspondence right
up until the time of Nobels deaf.
She in fact became the recipient of the
Nobel Peace Prize in 1905 some weeks
after birth or left his employee,
Nobel Matt,
a young woman by the name of Sophie has,
despite the fact that Alfred was 43 and
Sophie was just 20 they entered into a
relationship.
There was the last for 18 years,
apparently embarrassed by the age gap.
Nobel kept their relationship a secret,
the age difference with not the only
thing that seemed to work against the
relationship.
Sophie was uncouth and educated and
it'll manage their relationship.
It was a toxic one. In 1891 Sophie
became pregnant to another man,
but Alfred held out hope for their
relationship until she married the child's
father. Three years later, even then,
he sent her an annual allowance
of 6,000 Florence Nobel
never had any children.
Despite his immense wealth.
He filled his days with work,
often going nonstop for 20 hours.
In 1875 he invented Jelic nights,
which proved to be a safer
explosive than dynamite.
In the late 1860s Alfred's sat up at
number of clients across Europe and the
United States.
In June of 1866 he started the
United States blasting Iowa company,
the first nitric company in the US.
He also spend increasing amounts of time
and money protecting his pattern does
inventions from fraudsters who tried
to make money off his hard work.
Alfred was convinced that his invention
of dynamite who would ultimately be good
for mankind,
saying that my dynamite Walt sooner
lead to peace then a thousand wells
conventions.
As soon as men,
we'll find that in one instant hole
on his can be utterly destroyed.
They surely will abide in golden piece
as history has borne out his faith in
mankind.
It was sadly misplaced in 1869 while
traveling in Florence Nobel and that Paul
Barb at graduates of
the echo polytechnique,
Bob who came from an affluent
family was fascinated with no bells,
dynamite and proposed partnership.
He offered to finance the production of
dynamite in France and told me that he
wanted to learn how to produce it himself.
He had no bells interest.
Mainly because France was envied in the
industry for the state monopoly that had
held over explosives production.
The two men came to an agreement by
which all profits would be split.
50 50 the fringe enterprise was a success
and it soon expanded to factories in
Spain, Switzerland. Ethnicity.
In 18 eight Alfred set his sights on
establishing a dynamite company in
England's.
He considered this to be the prime
location as it would open up at the entire
British empire as this new market.
He spent several months traveling around
Britain's mining districts looking for
suitable factory locations. The Best Johns
is for investments came from Scotland.
After much negotiation,
the British dynamite company was formed
in 1871 Alfred purchased a four story
mansion and to state in Paris.
What does the Green House for his prize
orchids and stables for his beloved
horses, the SDS. It also had a private
laboratory for the next decade.
Alfred spend the bulk of his time working
in this lab along with his assistant.
Was George a Fehrenbach?
It was here that he discovered what he
considered to be dynamite 2.0 Jack Knight.
Jack Ignite was not any
more stable than dynamite.
It calls the greater explosion and was
easier to shape overall the substance.
It was simply much safer and
easier to handle than dynamite.
The new invention was
and even greater success.
The dynamites and Dick caused even more
money to flow into the Nobel coffers in
1891 now for the grand dissatisfied with
the facilities and as Paris mentioned,
the borrower tree,
he bought another a stage.
This one located some 15 miles from
Paris and the town of sovereign. Yeah,
he builds a larger and
better equipped to lab.
He based himself in the town bus run
into problems with the French authorities
when he refused to comply with the
new regulations and policies which he
considered to be unnecessarily
restrictive. Amazing. The,
the French government charged
him with high crimes and treason.
He was forced to poses new lab ones.
You left for Italy,
the French government for bade him from
ever working in that country again.
Prior to his asked from France.
Alfred's had been working on his
latest invention Ballis state.
He continued this work.
It isn't new lab in San Reno in Italy.
About that stage was a
smokeless propellants that
combines nitrocellulose since
Nitroglycerin,
the rights to the new explosive.
What leads to the Italian government.
He began using the m one
eight nine zero Vasily rifles,
which used cartridges that
were loaded with Balla state.
Alfred's brother Ludvig died in
1888 the newspapers, however,
reported that it was the far more famous
Alfred he would pass away. As a result,
his Nobel had the rare
experience of reading his own
obituary. What do you read?
It shocked him to his core.
Virtually every newspaper that he looked
at seemed to glory and his suppose
demise.
One French headline announced the merchant
of death is dead and other reports
stated Dr Alfred Nobel,
the Musa later who became rich by finding
ways to kill more people faster than
ever before died yesterday.
Nobel was devastated that the realization
that the end result of his life's work
was to be worldwide condemnation.
He decided that he had to do something
to turn around his reputation and
whatever time you had left.
In 1893 Alfred employed a
personal assistant by the
name of Ragnar Soleman and
appointed him as the executor of his will.
The two men worked diligently on the
documents over the next two years.
Then on November the 27 1895 Alfred signs
the will of the Swedish Club in Paris.
It was a well like no other.
Alfred left 94% of his total wealth,
the equivalent of 265 million,
$2,018 to the awarding of a number of
annual prizes to individuals who according
to the well during the proceeding year,
have conferred to the
greatest benefit on mankind.
The wills spelled out five categories,
physics, medicine, chemistry,
literature and peace.
The peace prize was to be given to the
person who has done the most or best work
for fraternity between the nations and
abolition or reduction of standing armies
into the formation and spreading
of peace congresses. Today,
there is a six category economics,
but this was not added until
the end of the 20th century
and his late fifties Nobel's health
was increasingly causing him problems.
His heart was especially weak and
it attempts to self medicated.
He began administering
doses of Nitroglycerin.
There's quite likely contributed
to his deteriorating state.
His body finally gave out on December
the 10th 1896 following a stroke.
He was 63 years of age. Nobel prizes
began to be awarded five years later,
the Nobel prize for peace.
So today's video is a great example of
our science can be used for both good and
for bad.
And Alfred Nobel is not alone in his
position in history as someone who used
science to create something
truly devastating. But if
we cannot understand it,
we cannot hope to control it. And when
it comes to understanding science,
there's really no better place
to do that than it brilliance.
They all relenting platform,
which teaches you through
something called active learning.
Basically this means that instead of
staring at some text and complicated
diagrams and equations,
you solve problems actively.
I've been using brilliant to get a feel
of how this works and it's a bit like
this I don't know about sitting down when
I was a student looking at a textbook
and reading a paragraph and then
having no idea what really happens.
I'd go back over it again and again and
I'm still not really get it or get it a
little. What brilliant has
absolutely none of that.
Each thing you read is immediate.
The applied,
I chose a random topic and brilliant as
an example for this message and in five
minutes I understood what vectors,
Skylar's and displacement,
where in physics it's pretty crazy because
if those were just written down in a
paragraph like I mentioned before,
I'd just be like they were the
what now it would make no sense.
This is why brilliant is so great.
If you like learning and I'm going to
guess you all because you're watching a
channel like this one,
you will love brilliance.
It's such the way to master complex
scientific concepts to support biographics
and to learn more about brilliance.
Please go to brilliant.org/biographics
and sign up for free.
I'll say the first 200 people
to go through that link,
we'll get 20% off the premium
annual subscription. So as always,
I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next one.
Yeah.